- All right, everybody.
Let's wrap up with one
last feel good story
from the feeds of social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(Upbeat music)
(Audience clapping)
Every weekend a North
Carolina couple serves up
a Sunday Funday feast for their neighbors.
These are seriously awesome
meals like Carolina dogs with
homemade chili,
barbecue chicken sandwiches
with crunchy slop
and vegetarian rigatoni for the others.
(Laughs)
And get this the dish out, all
these amazing meals for free.
That's incredible. There's only one catch.
There's no takeout people that's
because chefs Joey and
Scott want you to stay
and connect with the
community, which is super cool.
We have Joey and Scott
dialed in from Charlotte.
(Audience Applause)
They watch weekdays
at 5P, WCCB show ,CW.
So Joey,
I'll start with you. How
did this all get started?
- Well we opened the
NoDa, our Company Store
in our neighborhood.
It's a funky little
eclectic neighborhood here
in Charlotte, North Carolina.
We opened it in the spring
of 2016 and one weekend.
It was a beautiful day.
It was a beautiful Sunday
and we both had to work
and we loved to barbecue.
And so we decided to just
roll our grill from our house,
up to the store and cook
out a few hamburgers.
I think we serve maybe 10
or 15 people at that point.
And we enjoyed the conversation so much
and getting to know our neighbors,
that we decided to do it
again the following week and
- The following week.
- Yep, and the following week.
And so fast forward five years,
and we've been doing it every week.
Now we serve about 150 to
200 plates. And of course,
Scott and I,
have gotten to meet a ton
of wonderful people as well.
- That amazing.
(Audience Claps)
It's such a cool thing you're doing,
but Scott, you don't
just do burgers and dogs.
These meals are super elaborate, right?
- Right. We love to get
inspired by different things,
different foods we're trying.
And so we'll do some things like Kimchi,
which is something that
specialists have to ferment for a
couple of weeks. If not more,
we've done marinated flank steak tacos,
where the meat has to
marinate for a few days,
leading up to the meal, we make
our own homemade hot sauces.
And so it, it, you know, we,
we put in a lot of time and
effort and everything into this,
but we love to cook.
And we really love seeing
strangers become friends
within our community.
And it's even been so much so that,
we know of at least two couples that met
at a Sunday Funday free lunch.
They're now married.
(Audience Applause)
And then we also had (Indistinct)
at a Sunday Funday that asked us,
if they could have their wedding sort of
at our store set up as a
Sunday Funday free lunch,
where they invited the whole neighborhood
and provided food to anyone
that wanted to show up
for their wedding.
And it was packed. It was wonderful.
(Audience clapping)
It's, it's something fun.
I mean, we're,
we're trying to create community
and we're literally
helping create families.
- I love that. Just bringing
the community together.
And I,
I love that it's not takeout
and people kind of have to sit
and hang that's. That's really cool.
I think especially people are
craving it right now as well.
For the last two years
we've been like so isolated.
So it's such a cool thing
to be able to do and get out
and just, (Audience clapping)
you know, interact with people.
Well, thank you so much, Joey and Scott,
I'm liking your post right now
and that's not all,
our season long partner
Pilot Pen that goes
deep into the Kelly Clarkson show,
likes to celebrate those
who create fearlessly,
just like y'all.
So they're going to be using
their friction erasable pen
to write you a check $4000.
(Audience clapping)
How does that sounds?
(Laughs)
- That's insane, thank you so much.
- That's a great reaction.
(Laughs)
Well thank you all so much , keep it up.